you're credited as like really moving
comedy forward in india like one of the
big guys that like help get us started
right
uh where do you want to see it go
i where do you where are you trying to
push it to
and how
i want to see i just want to see like
nine clubs in every city i would love to
see that and not in the big cities in
the small cities i'd love to see comedy
without consequence i'd love to see
political comedy religious comedy just
like and where it's
it's seems like nothing unusual at all
it just feels like something that
happens every day i'd love to see more
female comics in india like that's
something that i'd love to see there's
not enough right now there's like a big
sort of violence
like working female comics in india
maybe
30 35 it's a good amount i feel like
you're like you know yeah 30. that's a
lot yeah
how many female comics do you have here
oh
maybe 20.
20. i think that's i think i think i
think you're being i think we got
between 10. i think you're being
generous who you would consider a comic
like or like who everybody would
consider
two to four
wow two to four
is joan rivers still a lot three
[Laughter]
three
yeah so we need to raise the number
eddie izzard i think has become yeah
eddie is a woman now he's the one so
then back up to four
eddies is [ __ ] amazing
he's my dog he's incredible like that's
that's that's high like prior colin and
eddie hazard on my top three wow this
guy still wants to act you know what i
mean
next week
really that's your top three what about
rock what about patrice what about
chappelle i think you have like it's who
you grew up with right so i just wasn't
exposed to them when i was like growing
up but like carlin for just sheer not
give a fuckness yeah prior for
vulnerability in putting that into stand
up yeah and eddie is uh for saying
something that he clearly wrote and
making you feel like he made up the
entire show ah yeah so like that's why i
like those three guys yeah eddie yeah
he's great at that he can make it feel
like the first time and but it's all
written yeah and it's it's super craft
and it's all rehearsed yeah but he is
like the blend between like a stage play
and stand-up comedy yeah like a one-man
show and stand-up is is that still a
thing though like i think the british do
it a lot more than than we do here
but i feel like those lines are blending
as well right in terms of like what
stand up is i feel like that discussion
changes every single year yeah and
you're like no this feels like a one-man
show or this feels too cinematic or that
feels like a ted talk or i just it
changes if it's less jokes it's one
man's show
and if it's more jokes it's it's
standard if you can't be a successful
stand-up you do a one-man show yeah
interesting yeah yeah but what if
there's one theme in it but then like is
the american like our americans opposed
to like stand-up shows with narrative or
like with story to them no i think that
those people are incredibly successful
yeah i think that like
sometimes stand-ups
i feel like we're all thinking of the
same people and not saying it but anyway
like like a microglia or something like
that no but like that's pure
storytelling and yeah he's like he's a
georgia tech
like i feel like that's joke
neil brennan has joke heavy one-man show
absolutely hilarious okay uh baby is
funny burbiglie is a storyteller he's
mastered it right so it's like
would you call that a one-man show
basically i would call one-man show but
bigly could work those jokes out like
parts of those stories out on stage yeah
he was a successful stand-up yeah i
always wondered that like do
storytellers stand ups like pop into the
club yeah i think they work out the
stories there and i think that's how
they get them good
nice maybe that's what i would do i
would want the expectations of a
stand-up crowd if i'm killing with that
and then turning to the narrative and
then you separate yourself a little bit
i think that that's cool i think that's
good i don't think there's anything
wrong with it i do think that there are
people who go i'm a storyteller because
they're just not punching up their jokes
enough they don't want the expectations
of stand-up nice but i think the elite
storytellers and one-man show guys like
the eddie izzard guys
no comic is going oh yeah he's not that
funny he's just being a storyteller he
is stand-up funny
and happens to have this like
orchestrated beautiful piece yeah which
i think you could look at like
you know i don't want to say next level
because i love watching a chris rock or
a bill burr or like a patrice like i
like what they do and that's a little
bit more my style but i appreciate
somebody putting together a piece even
akkas like you put together a piece
there's a string of these jokes that all
had a similar theme that was the idea
yeah yeah yeah so you could say that
you're gay you're gay
you could say that you've been trying to
say it
i didn't know that you were one man gay
yeah yeah but you are i've been trying
to thank you for [ __ ] finally i
realized that if you and jay shetty got
together
i i should be so lucky yeah
i
i look at jay like why are you settling
yeah i mean nah bro yeah i think you got
just as pretty eyes
oh no he's got better cheekbones he's
got great cheekbones his eyes are like
icy blue
yeah he's crazy
rhythmic maybe like rita roshan is like
a big superstar gorgeous but he got
three thumbs
yeah two three i was like okay there's
another one on this yeah two thumbs on
one hand yeah i had a i had a driver
it's all why do you ever notice that why
is it you guys that always have like the
extra [ __ ] limbs and [ __ ] i don't
know this is true you always say this
and i don't think if there's a person
that's like born with like another leg
it's indian
why is that the kama sutra that's why
you shouldn't believe that
just because we're doing all the funny
[ __ ] right so
that's why stay away but is that a sheer
numbers thing and we just don't hear
about it from china because china
doesn't like promote it isn't everything
with us to share numbers
literally i'm wondering i just gotta
have some [ __ ] come on so you
answered
is that what they're putting in the camp
are they just finding all like the extra
limb first yeah they can get more work
done there you go build the toys yeah
you have an extra hand 100 yeah you're
putting on four wheels at once that's
crazy make a building in five minutes
[Applause]
you